NARRATOR: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of
MIT courses, visit
MITOpenCourseWare@ocw.mit.edu.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: So now
we go on to the breakdown
of the octet rule.
So we've established
the octet rule
and now we're going to shake
it all up and see its flaws.
So case 1, we're going to
consider what happens--
and this again is
today's handout--
consider what happens when
you have an odd number
of valence electrons.
Case 1, all right,
so for molecules
with an odd number of
electrons, odd number
of valence electrons, it's
not possible for every atom
to have a complete octet.
That involves
pairing, that involves
even numbers of electrons.
So let's look at an
example of a place
where we have an odd number
of valence electrons.
And this is our friend,
CH3, our methyl group
that we saw a few minutes ago.
So we can also
write it like this.
And we can come up with a Lewis
structure for our methyl group.
So hydrogen, remember, it only
brings one valence electron
to the table.
There are three hydrogens.
Carbon brings four
valence electrons.
So in sum, we have seven,
an odd number of electrons.
To complete our
octets-- remember,
hydrogen is an exception,
it only needs two,
it just has that 1s orbital--
so we need two electrons for it
for it to be happy.
There are three hydrogens.
That's six.
Carbon needs eight.
So total you need 14 to make
carbon and hydrogens happy.
So if you consider then how
many bonding electrons you have,
that's the number of electrons
needed for your octet,
minus the number of
valence electrons you have,
so we get seven
bonding electrons.
How do you have seven
bonding electrons?
A bond has two electrons in it.
So let's look at
that, what do we do.
Well, we can put
six-- six is good--
assign two electrons for
the bond between this carbon
and this hydrogen, two between
this carbon and this hydrogen,
two between this carbon and
this hydrogen, six is good.
But now what do we do
with the extra one?
We have seven.
So we're just going to stick
that right there on the carbon.
So what is this molecule, then?
Well, what this molecule
is is a radical species.
So a radical species
is a molecule
with an unpaired electron.
And usually radical
species are very reactive.
Bonding electrons don't
want to be unpaired,
they want to be in bonds.
So they're highly reactive,
they're sort of searching out
to either get rid
of their electron,
to get another electron.
They're very, very
reactive species.
So radicals turn out to be
very important in human health.
And free radicals in biology
are both good and bad.
So in the bad category,
we have the fact
that free radicals damage
DNA, that leads to mutations
in cancer and death.
Not good.
And there are a lot of
radical species, many of which
involve oxygen, oxygen
radical species that
can be byproducts of metabolism,
common cigarette smoke.
So there are natural
causes and also
man-made causes of
radical species.
And this is very harmful.
But radical species can
also be really good.
So they're also
essential for life.
They're signaling
agents in the body.
Radicals are short-lived,
they're highly reactive,
so they're not around very long.
That's a great signaling agent.
You want the signal
to turn itself off,
so you want to have
something short-lived.
They're also essential
for enzyme reactions.
We have no cell division,
no growth, no multicellular
organisms if it weren't
for radical enzymes.
And we use radicals
in our body when
we're fighting off illness.
We generate radical species,
or the white blood cells
do, to kill invading microbes.
So we're using radical
defense in our bodies
to fight off illness.
So radicals are
both good and bad.
So we talked about oxygen
radicals a little bit.
One other radical
species is nitric oxide.
And now why don't you identify
for me which of these molecules
is nitric oxide, knowing
that it's a radical?
All right, just 10 more seconds.
OK, so some of you
might have just known
that that molecule
is nitric oxide.
But if you had done
the calculation,
you would have
realized that NO is
the only one where you get
an odd number of bonding
electrons.
For these other molecules,
you have an even number
and they can't be radical
species with an even number.
You need an odd number
of bonding electrons
to have a radical species.
So this is nitric oxide, NO.
And what does NO do?
So NO is an important
signaling molecule in the body.
So it activates something
called guanylyl cyclase, which
is an enzyme, which then starts
a second signaling system that
involves GTP forming another
signaling agent, cyclic GMP.
And this causes vasodilaiton.
So scientists were very
interested in this pathway,
and they noted
that cyclic GMP can
be degraded by an enzyme
turning off this signal.
And they thought, if
we inhibit this enzyme,
then we can have a
more continued effect
of vasodilaiton.
This could be good
for people who
are suffering from
heart disease,
they need to get more
oxygen to their lungs,
they might have emphysema.
This could be a very good
thing for these people.
So they designed an
inhibitor for this,
but it turned out it didn't
work exactly as they expected.
It did increase
vasodilaiton, but only
in one part of the body and only
for one gender of individual.
So this led to the bestselling
pharmaceutical molecule
of all time.
So a good example of how science
sometimes doesn't take you
exactly where you wanted
to go but nonetheless
was highly profitable.
All right, so
nitric oxide-- and I
could tell you
that actually a lot
of the early work on nitric
oxide was done at MIT.
And for people
who came from MIT,
there's a whole just-say-no
club here at MIT.
And if you see this just-say-no,
it's about nitric oxide.
So just be aware of that.
OK, so now let's do a
Lewis structure for this
and see this radical species.
So again, we need an odd
number of valence electrons,
if it's going to be a radical,
and that's what we get.
So nitrogen has five valence
electrons and oxygen has six.
So overall, we have 11.
To have complete octets,
nitrogen needs eight,
oxygen needs eight, so we need
16, which gives us five bonding
electrons, 16 minus 11.
That makes it a radical species.
And now we have six remaining
and we can put everything on.
So we can put four bonding
electrons in between.
We have five, we
can only put four
because you can't have a
bond with just one electron.
So the fifth one is why
it's a radical species.
But we have also six
remaining valence electrons.
And we can distribute those
around one, two, three, four,
five, six.
And that would be our molecule.
All right, so this is a highly
reactive radical species.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How do you know
that the radical one goes
on the end instead
of [INAUDIBLE]?
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
Yeah, I actually
was going to calculate
whether we could use this,
but that is in fact
where that one is going.
So that can be a clicker
question maybe for next time.
I didn't actually get to try it.
I was thinking, we should
calculate the formal charges
and think about where
things are going to go,
but I didn't do that.
But that's a good question.
All right, so let's just
look at another example.
Let's look at molecular oxygen
for a minute and do this one.
So we're getting lots of
practice with Lewis structures
today.
So we need to think
about valence electrons.
So we have six for
oxygen plus six,
so we have 12 valence electrons.
And we need eight plus
eight, we need 16.
Then we need to figure out
how many bonding electrons.
That's going to be
16 minus 12, or four.
And now we can assign.
And so we'll put first
two, and we have two more.
So we're going to assign them.
We have two more, and
we'll put those in.
So we have a double bond.
And then we can think about
whether we have any left.
And we had 12 valence electrons.
Now we've used four,
so we have eight more
that we can distribute.
So we're going to make
some lone pairs here.
So we can put two up
here, a lone pair up here,
a lone pair down here.
One, two, three, four--
our eight extra electrons.
And that looks lovely.
Everything is happy.
That seems like a
great structure,
except for the fact
that it's wrong.
Lewis structures have failed us.
So it turns out that
it's a biradical.
And this is really why we
live life as we know it.
Oxygen-- there was a
time before oxygen,
life was very different.
Oxygen came around,
changed life as we know it,
partly because it's a biradical.
It has amazing properties,
it can do amazing chemistry.
It allows us to break down
sugars and make energy.
And so in reality,
oxygen is a biradical.
We know that it is not a
double bond, as drawn there.
This is the structure.
We have one bond, not a
double bond, lone pairs.
But then we have a
single dot over here,
a single dot over here.
That makes it a biradical.
One radical on this oxygen,
one radical on that oxygen.
And we can't explain this
with Lewis structures.
We need molecular
orbital theory.
But you're in luck
because that's
what we're going to
talk about on Monday.
So Monday, I'll explain to
you why this is a biradical,
but you're going to
have to wait for then.
Because we have more
problems to address first,
we have octet
deficient molecules.
Some of these atoms, they're
just messing everything up
for us.
OK, but the good news is,
octet deficient molecules--
incomplete octet.
There's only two of them you
need to know-- boron, aluminum.
There they are, just those two.
So let's look at boron.
So we have boron
and three fluorines.
So we put boron in the middle,
three fluorines around it.
How come I'm not putting
a fluorine in the middle?
Yeah, fluorine is always
going to be terminal,
it does not want to
be anywhere else.
OK, so now we can look at
part of the periodic table.
We see here is boron.
Right below it, aluminum.
So that helps us remember
those exceptions,
they're right there.
And now let's just calculate
this Lewis structure
and see about the
octet deficiency.
So normally we would say boron
has three valence electrons.
And fluorine-- there
are three fluorines,
it has seven, then 24.
OK, that actually
would always be true.
But now we're saying
boron should want eight--
and we'll come back
to that assumption--
to have complete octet.
That's definitely how much it
wants to have a complete octet,
but doesn't really
need a complete octet.
Fluorines also want eight.
That's a total of 32.
And now, if we subtract, we
have eight bonding electrons.
So we can assign
two per bond first.
Now we've used six,
and we have two more.
So we have two extras
that we can put in,
that gives us a double bond.
We can look at our
extra electrons.
We had 24, we used eight now to
do bonding, so we have 16 left.
And so we can put
two on this fluorine
that has the double bond.
We can put six on the
fluorine with the single bond,
and another six
on this fluorine.
And that adds up, that's great.
And now we can
assign formal charges
and think about how
good this structure is.
So if we do the formal charges,
let's look at boron first.
So it had three
valence electrons,
it has no lone pairs, and
it has half of eight bonding
electrons, minus 1.
Not bad for a formal charge.
What about this fluorine
with the double bond?
And that's a clicker
question, I told you
you'd be really good
at formal charges
by the end of class today.
OK, 10 more seconds.
I think we can get in the 90's.
Ah, it's killing me.
All right, we have to
keep working on it.
There's going to be more
clicker competition Friday.
There will be a formal
charge question on it.
And by the way, it's
OK to sit in groups.
We've had back-to-back
wins of one recitation.
I have noted that some
of them sit in a group.
Just saying that is allowed.
OK, so here, we have seven
valence electrons for fluorine,
and there were four
lone pair electrons.
Half of four bonding
electrons, so we
have a plus 1 charge there.
And then let's finish up.
So our single-bonded fluorines,
seven minus six lone pairs
for those.
And they have one
bond, so they have
half of two bonding electrons,
and then there's zero.
Overall, this is a
neutral molecule.
So we have plus 1, minus 1,
that's a neutral molecule.
This all seems good, except
that someone did an experiment
and found that all
three boron fluorine
bonds were single bonds.
So again, Lewis
structures failed us.
Experiment tells us
it's a single bond.
And this is in fact the
correct structure here.
Poor boron has an
incomplete octet.
So it does not have
all the electrons,
but it's happy with that.
It's OK with that because
it's one of the exceptions.
And if we look at the
formal charges for it,
now we have boron, it had
three valence electrons,
no lone pairs, half of six
bonding electrons is three.
So now it has a
formal charge of zero.
And all three fluorines,
we have seven minus six,
they have one bond, so half
of two bonding electrons,
they also have a
formal charge of zero.
So most elements would
not be OK with this.
But boron, with its
three valence electrons,
thinks that this is just fine.
So it's one of the exceptions.
And again, we wouldn't
have known this
except for experimental data.
Lewis structures
work 90% of the time,
but there are some where
experiment tells us
that the structure
we normally would've
done with our rules of
complete octets don't hold.
OK, and we can rationalize
this by the fact
the formal charges are more
favorable on this molecule.
One more exception--
valence shell expansion.
This again, is not a
property of just any atom.
It needs to be elements
that have been an n.
What is n again?
n stands for?
AUDIENCE: Principle
quantum number.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Principle
quantum number, yes.
You can't forget anything,
we're coming back to it,
we're coming back to all of it.
Have a principle
quantum number that's
equal or greater than three.
And what do we know about
things, what kind of orbitals
do we start talking about
when we have principle quantum
numbers of n that are
equal to or greater
than three, what happens?
AUDIENCE: d-orbitals.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: We get
some d-orbitals, exactly.
d-orbitals-- I love d-orbitals.
Closer to Thanksgiving,
we're going
to have a whole unit where
we're talking about d-orbitals.
We save that for a
really special occasion.
I love d-orbitals.
d-orbitals allow
for all sorts of
craziness to happen,
including valence
shell expansion.
So this is most common when
the central atom is large
and it has a bunch of little
small, electronegative atoms
around it.
And the transition metals,
with their d-orbitals,
they like this.
And other things with d-orbitals
are cool with this as well.
So the first example
we're going to look at
is phosphorus with five
chlorines around it.
Phosphorus is
pretty large, and it
has chlorine, which is a
fairly small electronegative
atom around it.
And it has five
of them around it.
So we'll put our
phosphorus in the middle
and we'll put our five
chlorines around it.
Now we need to count
valence electrons because we
need to draw Lewis structures.
So phosphorous brings five
valence electrons to the gain.
The chlorines each have seven,
and there are five of them.
So we have 40 altogether.
Phosphorus, we
think, wants eight.
It would, for a complete octet.
Also, chlorine wants eight,
and there are five of those.
So total, if we have complete
octets, we need 48 electrons.
48 minus 40, the number
needed for the complete octet
minus the number of
valence electrons
gives you eight
bonding electrons.
So we're going to assign
two per bond, up to eight,
and there we go.
Now does that look like a
good Lewis structure to you?
AUDIENCE: No.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Yeah,
it's pretty obvious
that there's
something wrong here.
So this is not
going to work out.
We're not going to add
chlorine to another chlorine
because they don't
like to do that.
Halogens really
like to be terminal.
So that's not going to work.
So we've got to use some extra
electrons and make a new bond.
So we need to have
five bonds, so that
means we need to use 10.
We need to have 10
bonding electrons.
And when we borrow another
two, we can make another bond.
We had 40, we've now used 10.
We had no choice, we had to use
10, so we have 30 lone pairs.
And we have five chlorines
that all want six lone pair
electrons to complete their
octet, and six times five
is 30, so this works
out beautifully.
So this is a very
happy structure now.
Phosphorus is OK, it's large.
It has an n equal 3.
It's OK being expanded,
and chlorine is very happy.
So the bottom line is there
are certain kinds of elements
that you can expand.
They can have more
than an octet.
They can have five bonds.
Others, carbon-- no, carbon is
not going to have five bonds.
But phosphorus is OK.
So some things can be expanded,
some things can't be expanded.
So you have to think about
what the expansion would do
and whether that
would be allowed.
Let's do one more example.
Chromium with four
oxygens, minus 2 charge.
We see chromium over here.
It's got d electrons.
Let's see what happens.
So here we have our
skeleton structure.
We put chromium in the middle
and our four oxygens around it.
Now we have a bracket around
it with a little minus 2.
Note the minus 2 because
it has a charge on it.
Don't forget about the charge.
And now we need to see how
many valence electrons.
So chromium is
going to bring six.
So we can look at where it is in
the periodic table-- one, two,
three, four, five, six.
Our oxygen is up here.
Also, have six
valence electrons.
And don't forget about the
charge on the molecule.
So when it's minus 2, you
have to add two electrons.
It has extra two
electrons, so add those in,
which gives you a total of 32.
What do you need for your octet?
So eight for the
chromium, four times eight
for all the four oxygens.
We need 40, then we can
take our 40, minus 32,
and we have eight
bonding electrons.
That seems good, two per bond.
We'll put those on.
Then we'll see if we have
any lone pairs, and we do.
32 minus eight gives us 24.
The oxygens are
going to want six,
and there are four of them,
so that just looks awesome.
So maybe this doesn't
need to expand.
Let's see.
What do we do to test this?
Experiments, or, if we
don't have a lab, we do--
AUDIENCE: Formal charge.
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
Formal charge.
Yes, that's easier to
do in the classroom.
All right, so we'll
calculate a formal charge.
Chromium brought six
valence electrons.
It has no lone pairs, it
has half of eight bonding
electrons, or four
bonds, plus two oxygens,
have six valence electrons, six
loan pairs, one bond, so half
of two, or minus 1.
So the total charge here,
because you have four
of those, plus 2, is minus 2.
So that's OK.
But this has a pretty
big charge distribution.
Everything has a
formal charge on it.
And that doesn't make
molecules very happy,
they want formal charges of
zero, maybe plus or minus 1.
But this is a lot
of formal charge.
So maybe we can do better.
And as someone
said, someone else
did an experiment and-- yup--
they're not single bonds.
So the experiment showed
that it's somewhere
between a single
and double bond.
So this is not the
right Lewis structure.
And one of the tip-offs could
be, whenever you see plus 2,
make sure there's not another
possible structure, or minus 2.
So you can make
double bonds here.
And if you do that and
calculate the formal charge then
on chromium, it had
six, no lone pairs,
but now it has six bonds, so
it has a formal charge of zero.
The double-bonded oxygens had
brought six valence electrons,
they have four lone pairs, and
they have half of four bonding
electrons, now they're zero.
And the two single oxygens
here are still minus 1.
There are two of them, so
that equals the minus 2.
But this has much less
charge separation.
You have lots of zeros.
You don't have any more
things with charges of 2.
But this is not done.
What else do we need here?
AUDIENCE: Resonance structures.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: We
need resonance structures,
that's right, because I just
put the double bonds here.
I could have put them there,
or maybe somewhere else.
And you can tell me how
many other structures
you need to complete this.
All right, 10 more seconds.
Yup, this is a
good one, I think,
that helps when you
do it in a team.
Everyone sees different ones.
So there actually
are four other ones.
You can try to write that
out and prove it to yourself.
There are four other
structures you can do.
And you need all of those to
get the correct structure.
So these structures are correct,
it is a resonance structure.
There's less formal
charge separation.
OK, so that's the end
of Lewis structures.
And we're going to talk about
shapes and molecules on Friday.
And problem set
is due on Friday,
and it has lots of
Lewis structures
in it, so don't leave
it to the last minute.